I gang in this gang in Busbee right here
Oh what's good everybody my name's
pigeon we out here in my head and
talking to people trying to figure out
what they know about intercept would you
like to be in my BuzzFeed video
I'm just here asking people what they
know about innocence and then it's just
fun and I give you candy after ok
community my name is pigeon I'm from
Chicago and I was born intersex have you
heard that term before no I haven't what
do you think an intersex question is to
me it sounds like ooh you wanna inside
I think of intercourse in a way so maybe
like a combination of multiple sexes you
like English major or something you like
know the root words and everything
etymology intersex is an umbrella term
for a person born with sex traits that
don't easily found either or category of
what Society defines is usually as male
or female what kind of like a mixture or
blending okay so let me go to our next
question
intersex people are as common as natural
born redheads true or false
intersex is 1.7 percent of the human
population and so is ready did you think
intersex was less common or more common
well before I thought it was less Conor
now I think it's more common we are
there next question true or false
intersex and transgender are the same
exactly both false
was it true there is a bit more about
the body and the biology and transgender
is more about the gender and how your
gender identity is but initial people
can be trans if they so decide
cool now you say something oh you're
typing this is my fourth question true
or false
all intersex people are LGBT identified
fast Oh
for me but not for all innocent people
so um you can be straight and instill
the innocence but you can also speak
LGBTQ so about intersex and
hermaphrodite is a term that should and
could be used interchangeably oh wow I
don't know I would say both yes actually
intersex people used to be concur
Meredith but today is considered like a
slur what's the other word for slur
I'm fences an offensive outdated term
and it's just not physically possible
human beings anyway so it was a misnomer
now the most important question can I
give you a hug okay thank you for energy
I got candy for you yeah okay okay take
Louise um rainbow Bacon's off the top
you're very nice are you saying that cuz
we're giving you candy or do you really
think that oh okay great
[Music]